what is it that actually drew wanda and
vision together
episode 8 of wandavision revealed the
origins of wanda's powers
and the connection she formed with the
mind stone during hydra's experiments
which makes us wonder were wanda and
vision only drawn to each other because
of the mind stone
i think you missed that
the origins of both wanda and vision are
tied to the mind stone
wanda first comes in contact with the
stone during hydra's experiments
which reawakened and enhanced her powers
as soon as wanda enters the room with
loki's scepter
the mind stone is drawn to her showing
her a silhouette resembling her classic
costume from the comics
it reacts to wanda's presence right away
and soon after becomes a constant
presence in her life
the maximoff twins team up with ultron
who using technology stolen from tony
stark placed the mind stone into a
physical
biosynthetic body that would later
become the vision
i wish to understand it given the ties
wanda and vision's powers have to the
stone
it makes sense that vision is able to
break wanda's control over people's
minds within the hex
it can also explain how he is resistant
enough to her powers that he begins to
question their reality in the first
place
interestingly wanda's magic is usually
represented with her signature color
red however when she creates vision
within the hex
he manifests in yellow light before
taking physical form
the same color as the mind stone
implying that some of the stone's power
may reside within her this is further
reinforced when sword and hayward
successfully reanimate vision's corpse
using residual energy from an object
wanda cast her magic
on this means that wanda's magic is
influenced by the mind stone
or it is at least similar enough to the
stone's powers that it can produce the
same effects
i don't know how i did it
all that being said wanda and vision are
more than just the mind stone
while the stone may have influenced her
powers we know that wanda had magic
long before hydra experimented on her
according to agnes her powers are chaos
magic
in marvel comics and even the movies
magic has to come from somewhere
while wanda is a mutant like the x-men
the power she wields originates from the
nexus
which was name-dropped in one of the
commercials in the form of a red pill
as for vision's origins it took much
more than the mind stone to create him
jarvis ultra tony me the stone
the creation of mcu's vision was truly a
team
effort tony stark and bruce banner
experimenting with the mind stone create
ultron in his efforts to become a
perfect being
ultron stole the cradle technology from
tony stark
and used it to create a body that would
physically merge him with the mind stone
the avengers intercept the cradle and
tony's ai assistant jarvis is placed
into the android
put jarvis into this thing no
for a finishing touch thor uses his
lightning to bring him online
you're saying vision isn't just the
stone if we take out the stone
there's still a whole lot of vision left
shuri even gets part of the way through
the process of separating the two
but runs out of time leaving wanda no
choice but to rip the stone from his
head
however given shuri's level of genius
and expertise
if she claims that she could separate
them we're inclined to believe her
can you do it
given all of this it seems like the mcu
is trying to tell us that vision is more
than the sum of his parts
he was built powered and influenced by
so many sources that he isn't just the
mind stone
thank you vision's personality might be
completely separate from the stone
in avengers infinity war vision
describes it as something strange and
unknown to him
despite it being part of his body he
even says it's as if it's speaking to me
implying that there is a degree of
separation between the two when wanda
goes to read his mind she tells him
i just feel you this could mean that the
stone
and vision are the same but another
interpretation is that vision's thoughts
are completely his own
and the mind stone doesn't factor into
it at all
despite all the messed up circumstances
the two find themselves placed in
their time together on screen in the
movies and the show has shown us a
deeply emotional connection
their relationship is built on
acceptance and understanding
despite fighting on opposite sides in
captain america civil war
it didn't tear them apart for long even
when wanda became a fugitive
under the sokovia accords the two of
them couldn't stay apart
arranging romantic rendezvous in secret
while wanda was in hiding with the rest
of team cap
vision became a source of comfort to
wanda and she accepted him
exactly as he was even if the mind stone
drew them to each other
it seems like it only played a small
part in their romance
it may have been the spark that lit the
flame but their genuine bond is what
kept that fire going
we are an unusual couple you know oh i
don't think that was ever in question
how could we say wanda and vision aren't
in love when we have scenes like this
where vision attempts to make paprika a
traditional dish from her homeland
to cheer her up if that isn't love we
don't know what
is